hello America my name is just Lane
Maxwell if you're watching this video
means all was arrested for no real
reason I didn't do anything neither did
Jeffrey we was good to the children we
had to hold our land to protect the
children from the police we had it was
our autonomous zone like Chad's in
Seattle I see you comrades reform is not
an option abolish don't E font get rid
of them
send a social worker out to handle me I
don't I've never met a social worker or
anyone that wasn't a king or a queen
really I was gonna call my autonomous
own Chester because I had a mate named
Chester Chester Roth child he was so fun
he's away now on a boat on in auntie for
now I don't want fascism I don't like it
how about getting rid of Donald Trump
how about that America your whole
country is racist that's why I bought a
mansion in the middle of nowhere to get
away from the racism my friend Hillary
Clinton got me this clutch and I really
appreciate it
she knows I suffer from anxiety and she
said if anything happens just take this
pill and I'll feel better and I will do
that and I appreciate that thank you
I'm being wrongly accused the only thing
I'm guilty of is wanting to end white
supremacy and the patriarchy I haven't
said anything publicly in a few years
because I've been so depressed by
Trump's election and there's a lot of
cyberbullying going on and it's at my
expense if you're going to arrest a
British woman of means arrest JK Rowling
she's a turf we need to abolish the
police tonight no White King we do it
tonight I don't want to see any police
on my property and no FBR and no CIA and
I'll used to lock the CIA we had a lot
of fun we did but not anymore because
it's racist I'm using my white privilege
to call out the real problem in this
country
Asian cops